les effets de la guerre en Ukraine sont
bien visibles à Paris
les réfugiés Ukrainiens arborent
fièrement le drapeau jaune et bleu
les Russes qui ont fui eux sont plus
discrets
comme tahitia et Vassili qui sont
arrivés en France avec leur fille de 5
ans en mars dernier quelques semaines
après le début de l'invasion russe je
pense
et je sais qui veut pas tuer les
ukraines
d'autres personnes
[Musique]
du régime les deux sont cinés à ces
artistes connus comme le militant
plusieurs fois arrêté par la police
russe dans le passé
veut manger de construire sa maison
c'est tout il n'y a pas de repas chaque
jour ils ont travaillé aux côtés de
l'ONG rue se mémorial décoré cette année
du prix Nobel de la paix qui les a
d'ailleurs aidés à fuir ils ont d'abord
été hébergés chez une famille française
avant d'emménager dans un hôtel parisien
grâce à des groupes de soutien
prison je pense que la Russie sera comme
le coréen Nord avec la frontière fermée
et pas de la manifestations des dizaines
de milliers de citoyens russes ont
commencé à fuir dès le début des
hostilités mais l'exode s'est intensifié
avec l'annonce de la mobilisation
partielle le 21 septembre nous sommes
arrivés ici ces deux hommes sont arrivés
en France il y a quelques jours deux
frères l'un et chercheur universitaires
en sciences sociales l'autre et
psychanalyste à Moscou ils étaient
opposés à cette guerre et craignaient
d'être enrôlé contre leur grippe il ne
souhaite pas être identifié pour
protéger leurs proches rester en Russie
et mon père une personne très réservée
qui n'a jamais dit quelque chose pareil
il a dit que tu dois quitter
c'était très
impressionnant je veux faire quelques
choses qui en fait va contre le discours
de la guerre que par contre
le logique
destructive de l'État pour eux
l'enlisement du régime dans la violence
et le mensonge devenait insupportable il
se disent bien accueilli en France n'ont
pas ressenti la russophobie présente en
Europe les gens qui peut-être supporter
la guerre avant mais ne se porte pas
avec la mobilisation je veux dire une
chose évidente celui qui veut fuir
maintenant il ne devient pas en autre en
soldat de Poutine s'il veut fuir il faut
l'aider c'est ça depuis le point de vue
de l'ONG française Russie liberté c'est
difficile de blâmer des gens qui
n'osent pas aller manifester parce qu'on
sait que en allant manifester ils seront
ils risquent jusqu'à 20 ans de pris
aujourd'hui
l'exode est difficile à quantifier la
George européenne Frontex évoque le
chiffre de 1 million de Russes qui
auraient fui depuis le début de la
guerre ce que nous demandons à l'état
français européen c'est de leur accorder
un statut spécial les ressortissants
russes que nous avons rencontrés n'ont
pas demandé le statut de réfugiés en
France parce qu'il serait forcé
d'attendre au moins cinq ans avant de
rentrer en Russie maintenant c'est une
caricature horrible
c'est l'enfer
il déplore que l'image de la Russie soit
aujourd'hui simplement associée à celle
d'un homme Vladimir Poutine le pays est
riche en histoire et en culture distille
il ne faut pas l'oublier et c'est ce qui
est malgré que tu dis existe encore en
Russie
of youtunes
[Rires]
je me retournais jamais à leur Russie
c'est comme le trauma pour moi
[Musique]